the parade marked the 90th anniversary
of the founding of north korea's
military and it was meant to show off
the power of its modern day weaponry
on display were some of the newest
weapons it has recently been testing
such as hypersonic missiles
and a more advanced longer-range
submarine-launched ballistic missile
after several years of attempted
negotiations aimed at denuclearization
leader kim jong-un seems to have
abandoned all such efforts at
conciliation
in the world today where powers are
fiercely clashing with other powers
national dignity sovereignty and true
peace can only be guaranteed by strong
self-defense to overcome an enemy
north korea's star of this show was what
it says is its most powerful
intercontinental ballistic missile to
date the hwasong-17
it's the same type of weapon it says it
launched at the end of march the first
fully fledged test of an icbm since
2017.
it seems north korea has nothing to lose
by putting on a big show of military
force right now us and south korean
forces have gone ahead with their joint
spring exercises south korea has just
chosen a conservative administration
that's likely to take a much tougher
stand with the north and u.s president
joe biden will soon be visiting
northeast asia president biden will be
attempting to bolster support from the
united states allies south korea and
japan
but there's mounting speculation that
north korea might even be planning a
return to underground nuclear weapon
testing for the first time in five years
the basic mission of our nuclear
capability is to deter war but our
nuclear weapons are not just for the
sole mission of deterrence if any
attempts are made to usurp our interests
we might have no choice but to call on
those weapons
pyongyang seems as determined as ever to
be accepted by the international
community as a nuclear power to be
reckoned with rob mcbride al jazeera
seoul